lightly fried my delicious Lumi and
courgette cakes squeeze every last bit
of flavor out of those vegetables
but first i'm preparing a simple slow
roast tomato and Watercress salad
these cherry tomatoes are perfect if you
haven't got cherry tomatoes Vita
Tomatoes good or even just big normal
plum tomatoes lay the tomatoes on the
tray
and these go into the oven for about 90
minutes
if you turn the oven down really low you
can leave them in overnight to be honest
the longer you leave them the better
they taste
once you've seasoned them with salt
sprinkle over with some sugar
on the salt and sugar combined speeds up
the drying process because you want that
nice chewy texture and then you get
these little thyme flowers and just pick
off the buds garlic sliced
then just spread that on
now the tray looks quite full and
compact for 90 minutes in the oven
you'll see everything shrink down all
the Skins blistering and the flavor
intensifies so nicely extra virgin olive
oil that gives a nice earthy flavor to
the tomatoes place your Tomatoes into an
oven preheated to 150 degrees C and cook
long and slow for an hour and a half
now halloumi cakes there's something
quite exciting about halloumi cheese
it's a very firm cheese and it fries
brilliantly
[Music]
fill the carrots
[Music]
great not too finely you want that nice
texture
next courgette the secret is keeping it
all grated the same put that into a
sieve
a sprinkling of salt will draw out
liquid from the vegetables
then grate the halloumi halloumi cheese
doesn't look that tasty but once you've
got color on it in the pan it's really
really delicious now
really important to squeeze out the
excess water from the veg and we'll see
all that water that needs to come out of
there if we didn't do this it'll make
your little patties non-friable because
the whole thing starts to separate and
then mix in with the cheese
spring onions chop up the whites and the
greens
now we're going to season that with some
delicious fresh mint and fresh coriander
whenever it's vegetarian I like to put a
combination of herbs in there tarragon
and parsley minted coriander basil and
lemongrass
all delicious on their own but in tandem
their flavors play off each other
next
two eggs in
give that a little mix
add the eggs to the mixture
and then finally a couple of tablespoons
of breadcrumbs the breadcrumbs help dry
out any excess moisture mix
all the ingredients together
before you start shaping these taste the
mixture
it's really important to identify the
seasoning now
if you wait until you've cooked them
it'll be too late to adjust the
seasoning
roll them to a large golf ball shape
them it's like a little mini burger
you can spice these up with some chili
in there if you haven't got fresh chili
chili flakes and it's something that can
be done up a day in advance
to get your cakes firm and ready for
frying put them into the fridge
uncovered for 25 minutes pan on get that
nice and hot boss and wait for that I'll
get the dressing ready
slice of red chili seeds and all on an
angle into shards
then chop fresh ginger
season with a Sprinkle of sugar and salt
add some rice wine vinegar
add a couple of tablespoons of olive oil
to finish off some chopped coriander
[Music]
because that's sweet sour spicy flavor
with my chili dressing done I can start
frying off my halloumi cakes in a hot
oiled pan
look at that nice crisp Edge
you can already start to smell that
sauteed halloumi with the courgettes and
carrots smells delicious really
important for a nice amount of color on
them
as my cakes Sizzle away I can finish off
with my roast tomato salad
one of my favorite leaves has to be
border Crest it's cut off stalks
[Music]
foreign
s
Watercress and shallot they're
brilliantly well together
shallot looks so dainty when you open up
these little ringlets
[Music]
don't forget to turn your cakes
now Tomatoes whatever you don't use just
jar them and put them in the fridge
[Music]
just drop those slow cooked warm
Tomatoes over the Watercress the
sweetness is incredible absolutely
delicious a little drizzle of age of
ultimate vinegar gives that tartness to
the watercress
Watercress is naturally peppery so it
doesn't need any pepper just a little
touch of salt
and then a light sprinkling of extra
virgin olive oil
after five minutes on a medium heat my
halloumi cakes are ready
so important to have taken out that
water
[Music]
you can see it doesn't disintegrate
and then just get your dressing take a
spoon of it and then tilt it to the side
because I want the garnish I don't want
the juice
but that does not
turn you on to become a vegetarian for
the night I honestly don't know what
will
delicious
[Music]
my crispy golden halloumi courgette and
Herb cakes with a Sumptuous roast tomato
and Watercress salad all of the flavor
with none of the meat
My ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage Hot Pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
no I love Hot Pot you love Hot Pot
and you love sausages right yeah what'd
you enjoy most about sausages
um I just love having them with a baked
beans sometimes with baked beans
sometimes these are
butter mushrooms okay you just take them
into there like that
and keep the hall and cut them into
quarters please now the important thing
about cooking sausages is they need a
bit of color right no color no flavor
exactly get the pan nice and hot how was
school today school was good thanks we
got to go out and make snowmen sausages
in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
darling
see
now
I want you to watch your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely
definitely now sausages
I get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of Daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah
yeah once you've got the color on them
and take them out
the rest okay
a little knob of butter okay into the
pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that'll go down by half give that a
little fry okay salt in
I want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
pack the flavor this feel nice smells
nice washrooms in give them a nice
little stir
did you like to help me make your hot
spot when she made them for you I used
to always help now make the hot pot
always now my mum would never have used
this but age balsamic vinegar brings out
the flavor of the onions right now look
at her onions look beautiful caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss I'm gonna put my sausages back in
here now from there
some red wine
red wine in
got the flavor underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look beautiful smell and it's
still not cooked yet up to the ball
really important to boil it here because
it won't boil in the oven 170 in the
oven literally
18 to 20 minutes and she goes nice
to go with my hot pot Rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and I'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
foreign
with a neat layer of potatoes and pour
the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin are bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the Apple compod what we need to
do first is to get these peeled and
sliced
I get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
foreign
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called Brae Burns what other apples do
you know cream ones what are they called
um
another word for your nan
Grandma's no
red no pink lady apples no Granny Smith
Granny Smith apples that's right what
we're going to do is cook the cooking
apples and
the eating apples together I love the
combination of the tartness from the
Bramley cooking apple with the sweetness
of the Brae bun get the pan nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
I want you to remember that because
we're going to look for them okay
because once we use them and they've
worked their magic I need to pull them
out see all the sugar dissolving
now we just let that go a little bit
darker
okay and then
replace it quick doesn't it
give that a nice
little toss
okay a nice golden color cinnamon in
ginger in so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
let me go into there what's that coming
out damp so that is a little bit of the
puree I'll show we'll do that in a
minute how many Ginger
four four Ginger
three cinnamon three cinnamon out with a
cinnamon
and the ginger gingers and take
spoon
of apples
bottom smells so nice how nice is that
look see the color of the apples
these in the fridge to get nice and cold
that's the Comfort sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to Crown the top you
separate the egg whites into there for
Daddy
right egg whites are in I think it's
separate off you got away
[Music]
and I'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
good girl
[Music]
there's your place now let's see if
you've got a really nice stiff peak so
you lift them up
now that is what I call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad next in a
separate Bowl whip double cream until
stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice
we're gonna put some delicious lemon
zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover Camry compote puree you mix
that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple butterscotch now
to make the cream even lighter fold in
those whisked egg whites and sugar egg
whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in
so we bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses yep
go
silly we're on for a treat open up the
Piping Bag now twist the end now you
could spoon this in I don't want to just
give a nice little lift it also gives it
a nice
lemon on top
the beetroot and potato gratin is that
lovely that's lovely
and sausages
finish with a flat leaf parsley
look at those two beauties it doesn't
get any more comforting than that does
it for one of the best hot pots
ever Tilly that looks amazing
in there well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by Apple compot